in five four three two one
what's going on everybody this is that
og genius brain cast with just me and
Joe today hello my PO a guest
sometimes dude let me tell you guys
something like you know people think
that podcasting is like the easiest
thing on earth it's not and there are a
few episode of the genius brain project
that I'm not gonna upload because a
couple of guests that I brought on and I
talked to them too and I told them
straight up they were boring as [ __ ] and
okay I couldn't not
I couldn't release it it was it was
weird because there are people who
arguably have way more interesting
stories than I do about my life but if
when they come on though their interest
or II is interesting they can't talk
yeah they can't tell a story talking's
an art man yeah it's like you ask him a
question and they'll be like yeah
elaborate people want to hear the story
yes bro
I literally brought you on so you could
tell that story and they just go yeah
man and sucked I think people get
self-conscious because I know a lot of
entertaining people off camera yeah yeah
yeah the camera turns on they just like
they get all small and [ __ ] like Alex
like that you know Alex that yeah yeah
yeah right
he's like when the camera turns on he
turns up this shy little boy and then
when it turns off he's saying every
racial slur on earth even even against
his own people you know so when I when I
first met Bart and Joe back in the day
they kept not talking about this guy
named Alex right or Alec and I it was to
me he was like a Greek mythology because
there were stories about him but I've
never ever seen him and so one time so
this is back in the day when I didn't
have my own office and I was just
working out at my apartment which I'm
doing now anyways but Bart Texas me and
I'm in the middle of doing something and
I forgot who I was with but I told that
person hey I gotta go something
important came up and the thing that
important thing that came up was that
Alex was in talent yeah and then he came
to the office yeah and it was so [ __ ]
funny because I when Bart I think Bart
when he tells his crazy stories he's
actual
giving you the soft version of who that
person is yeah because he's way more
intense in real life yeah yeah so the
moment I walked in the first thing I
hear this full say so Joe comes up goes
locked I haven't seen you write us how's
your daughter he goes why he tries
[ __ ] crazy
and he goes you gotta wait till she's 18
though at least when we went to go like
Korean barbeque cream barbecue and the
women to go hoop another day after that
and this fool just starts playing ball
in his [ __ ] bare feet yeah no shoes
dude is so [ __ ] funny man it's funny
because his family is like literally
mega millionaires maybe even a
billionaire like they work and they make
like chips for [ __ ] Microsoft and all
this [ __ ] right so he calls him money
but it has Billy but his parents don't
give him any yeah yeah and he's just as
straight like hillbilly because that's
the culture of his parents are just
straight he'll Asian hillbillies
that's [ __ ] crazy and then I heard
like in their language they I hear it
translated when I went over there just
they just talk [ __ ] all day to each
other his mom he talks about his mom
saggy titties and all this stuff that's
so [ __ ] funny and and to paint a
better picture of this wonderful
legendary creature he imagined like a
fat sumo wrestler that one he thinks
he's buff and not fast and he's bald he
has these chubby Buddha cheeks right
really big cheeks but he has black two
front teeth and [ __ ] smoking so many
cigarettes this video on YouTube I don't
know if it's still up but it's a video
back in the day so he used to actually
be Bart and Joe's match yeah we we let
him play the role of manager yes it was
funny because it was a video and was
when you told me about him thinking that
he's really buff and it's you making fun
of him because he has a pull-up bar yeah
and I'm like good you don't even use
that [ __ ] you had a pull-up bar he's so
fat you can't even do a pull-up you know
what the funny thing is too he would put
his arm next to Bart
[ __ ] flex and be like hey Joe don't
you wish your [ __ ] arms whereas bus a
buff as ours and I'm all looking at it
like bro that's the same size but it's
just all fat what are you talking about
that dude was I mean when I first met
him - it's it's so funny how you
described how he looked because he just
looked exactly like the way you said and
it's funny because he does live in his
own world
he's Humpty Dumpty dude lives in his own
world it's probably a good thing for his
self-esteem at the same time Chuck very
interesting guy and I have another
friend too that he reminds me of and he
actually was on this channel you want to
hear a [ __ ] crazy story so back in
the day the I forgot what bar it was in
Sacramento but I was in a bar at
Sacramento and a buddy of mine told me
this word he it was for a friend's what
do you call it bachelor party right and
when they were there there was a [ __ ]
crazy dude that was in the bar and he
was trying to hit on so it was a
bachelor party and a bachelor party
combined into this cup combination thing
they were trying to he was trying to hit
on the bride and so one of the groomsmen
came up to him say yo she's she's the
bride like she's not single and this
dude kind of got a little crazy flipped
out and he bare maced the whole got a
can of bear mace Wow so if you guys
don't know what bear mace is bear mace
is like regular mace but it throws out
this huge huge clout yeah it's it it
literally works on bears you could look
it up on YouTube and you'll see this
this can this gigantic can that sprays
out this huge cloud of just death so
crazy thing was I actually found out
later on that that person who did that
was my buddy Rob Wow
so Rob has his habit of when so I've
seen this dude literally come up to the
girl in the middle of a street and he'll
be like what's up baby what's your name
and she'd be like no I'm okay and this
will put his hand underneath her skirt
didn't touch anything
pulls it back and he goes yeah smells
like [ __ ] fish that he just walks
away
he's [ __ ] [ __ ] weird and I used
the friend I used the term friend very
lightly
- rod though this guy is [ __ ] odd man
this is this is some like low-key kind
of rape you level it's just he's so dumb
he doesn't understand I won't say Rob
you're not dumb dude you're just [ __ ]
weird bro like you just you don't
understand normal social context so
check it out so uh we our buddy of ours
just recently got married right
this dude shows up to the wedding and he
has his own camera there right and he
comes up to the bride and groom and he
goes so when are we gonna do your guys's
wedding photos what the [ __ ] is not the
set photographer my buddy looks at him
he goes what the [ __ ] told you you were
gonna take the photos like what are you
saying right now because he goes when
are we gonna [ __ ] do this photo shoot
I've been waiting all day man it's like
I never asked you to and then another
friend of ours was coming from the
airport and he called him to go pick him
up and he goes hey man I can't pick you
about I take these photos it's like
nobody's asking you to take the [ __ ]
phone he gave him some his own job at
the wedding
that's like me walking up and saying
damn man I gotta do this favor I'm DJing
[ __ ] David's wedding in [ __ ] and then
he's so [ __ ] odd when he showed up to
the wedding he dressed very nice like
decent right and then at the reception
this full dresses in a tuxedo at the
[ __ ] reception and it is the
trashiest looking tuxedo I've ever seen
in my life it looks like a tuxedo that
you've seen in an ACME cartoon that a
that a street rat wore with a tin can on
his head just tattered as [ __ ] and I
wouldn't even find such a dirty title
you know and I looked at him as I broke
you look good at the wedding
why didn't you change your outfit into
this ugly-ass tuxedo what are you doing
what's wrong with you oh he had to
change his outfit for the reception he
changed it for the reception why did you
just stay at his outfit I don't know
into a worse outfit and he somehow mate
he's the first person I know that ever
made it took C to look bad why would you
do that he's he's a [ __ ] odd
character see wait this was even a
groomsman no why would he switch it to
no [ __ ] no
you see the bride like oh you know I'm
going to a [ __ ] wedding I'm better I
better [ __ ] switch my outfit for
every occasion
dude there's so many weird stories I
have him like he's he does his weird
habit of oh so he tries to do this thing
where before somebody can make fun of
him he likes to make fun of himself but
when people do that normally it's a
defense mechanism and it makes other
people laugh yeah when he does it it
comes out of nowhere so one time him and
a bunch of our other friends came from
Sacramento and they were chilling in my
apartment right and when they were about
to leave we couldn't we couldn't find
where Rob is right and then we'll a
robber are you out we're all about the
bounce and he just comes out of nowhere
and he does awkward [ __ ] like this he'll
come out and he'll oh okay I guess I
just appeared at a [ __ ] fat ere this
goes dead silent like nobody nobody was
gonna call you fat probably you sick
right now this is so weird
he's like they're making they're making
invisibility joke cuz I'm fat yeah it's
like whoa you're not even making the
right mind connection yeah like what are
you saying right now and this dude is he
is he fat yeah he's fat oh so he just
automatically just starts bashing
himself nobody said anything about his
weight and this fool you had him on no I
have an atom on but if he does come here
I'm gonna have a monkey needs to explain
himself especially about that bear me
situation is I haven't taught him about
that [ __ ] but and even in that same day
he does some weird [ __ ] like this I this
is when I just started YouTube that he
goes you know David I want to support
you man and I just want to let you know
that I'm gonna follow you on everything
I got you right and this follows you on
Instagram Twitter everything and I'm
like bro how are you gonna follow me you
have a [ __ ] flip phone
he had a flip nokia phone oh he was
gonna go on a competing about I was like
bro who the [ __ ] are you gonna follow on
this brick what are you talking about I
have my ways like this was only like
five years ago so what the [ __ ] is he
doing with a Cano key a flip phone well
the the intent was there just a really
odd character [ __ ] the guy's odd this
podcast is brought to you by skill share
BAE BAE
if you haven't heard me talk about
Skillshare before well that's probably
because you're missing out on this
awesome deal so first of all if you
don't know what Skillshare is Skillshare
is an online learning community with
thousands of amazing classes covering
dozens of creative and entrepreneurial
skills you can take classes and
everything from photography creative
writing and a whole bunch more so
whether you're returning to a longtime
passion project challenging yourself to
get outside your comfort zone or simply
exploring something new Skillshare has
classes for you now for me I'm all about
lifelong learning just because you're
done with school just because you're
done with college it doesn't mean that
you should stop yourself from learning
new things and trying new things out I
believe that a lot of people out there
think that education stops after your
traditional education but it never
really does and that's what makes things
exciting for me I have a lot of hobbies
and there's a lot of things that I want
to learn and actually go to Skillshare
to pick up on a lot of these hobbies
like for example I love video editing
and skill sure has a bunch of tutorials
for that as well and I've been using
that for a while and has been helping
out a lot so check it out join the
millions of students already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for my listeners to get two months
of Skillshare for free that's right
Skillshare is offering genius brain
listeners two months of unlimited access
to thousands of classes for free to sign
up go to Skillshare comm slash brain
again go to Skillshare comm slash brain
to start your two months now that
Skillshare comm slash brain anyway so
for today's topic that everybody wants
to talk about and it's been kind of
dated because the special has been out
for a bit but the reason why I didn't
want to originally talk about this
because number one everybody was doing
it and then I just wanted to kind of sit
with the the stand-up special first and
then see what everybody was saying just
so like a form an opinion about it but
obviously if you guys know the king of
comedy himself Dave Chappelle put out
his special sticks and stones and it
really ruffled a lot of [ __ ] feathers
it's crazy cuz I didn't I didn't realize
that it it was worse than the other one
the [ __ ] killing me softly yeah I
mean he's I mean it's weird right
because when I watched it the first time
I I cracked the [ __ ] up yeah and the
great thing about Dave Chappelle stuff
is that when I watched it the second
third and fourth it got funnier funnier
yeah because there's a lot of stuff in
those jokes that I didn't really get at
the first passing because I was laughing
you're talking about killing minutes off
yeah because I laughed through I was
laughing through a joke and get to hear
the other stuff yeah so I watched it two
or three or four times and I think those
are the best stand-up specials where you
can watch it continuously yeah right and
so when I was watching the stand-up set
I was looking at there was like
something on Rotten Tomatoes where it
got a terrible [ __ ] added 0% yeah it
was at zero [ __ ] yeah and dude with
the day that it came out that's [ __ ]
crazy
yeah and so the the controversy behind
that is what Dave Chappelle stuff if you
haven't seen it if you have you probably
live under [ __ ] rock but it's um you
know he says a lot of stuff that in
today's society wouldn't be acceptable
right yeah because any topic I feel like
if you're if you're not making a joke
about how dumb people are for attacking
the LGBT community or you're not
champion that thing and you're not
making comedy light of people on the
other side yeah it's gonna be considered
as hate speech you're ignorant you're
not here with the times and so that's
what was happening I was reading a lot
of tweets where people were like even
some comics were coming at him they were
like you're you're you're dated you
don't know how to make good jokes
anymore that's funny all you see is like
shock value [ __ ] and it shocked me one
bit though it didn't shock me yeah I
don't know anyone that was mad with the
[ __ ] special yeah did you not my
friends I know I know of a really close
friend of mine who was dating a girl who
watched it he said he had to turn it off
really cuz she was so offended and guess
what is she gay no she says she just
found a lot of the stuff that he said
was very insensitive and he does not
date her anymore so well maybe we were
surrounded by [ __ ] bags because everyone
I know absolutely loved it yeah [ __ ]
loved it you know what there's I mean
the interesting thing is I guess to what
people were saying is like it's very
insensitive right they said that um it's
it's very dated the stuff that he's
talking about and to them it doesn't
make sense I guess for me in comedy it's
kind of weird right and I think we can
all be a little hypocritical depending
on what's being said and how it affects
us on our personal experiences right
but at the same time I'll put it like
this and how I see it sometimes is I
have to catch myself doing that because
if I try to censor comedy based on
specific things that happened to me yeah
then I'm I think I'm doing a disservice
to comedy Yeah right because comedy like
Patrice O'Neal is one of my favorite
stand-up comics and I only found out
about him
after he passed away really and I really
started looking at a stand-up which is
sad but Patrice O'Neal said it best he
goes when I do stand-up comedy half the
room should be terrified and the other
half the room should be cracking the
[ __ ] up yeah because comedy should be
polarizing because you are saying
something important yeah I mean it's a
form of philosophy - yeah right yeah and
you're you're saying [ __ ] that's
controversial and you're saying [ __ ]
that shouldn't be said sometimes and
that's why it's funny yeah
like you're you're tackling issues with
things that are taboo and comedy
supposed to be challenging and I don't
know why people don't understand that
yeah that was that was the part that
kind of throws me off a bit right
because I do want to preface this um for
those who think that oh I can't be
offended no you you a hundred percent
should and can be offended right it's
what you do after that you think should
happen because you personally are
offended that you shouldn't counsel
someone and shut somebody down if
they're not breaking any laws exactly no
so these are comedic sets that yeah I
say 80% found really funny maybe even
90% or maybe even 95 but that 5% dislike
is speaking up really [ __ ] loud and
the people who are in that 5% are saying
you should not do comedy now that
doesn't make any sense to me because
yeah you being offended is 100% in your
right and it's not wrong either it's
just the fact that you think that
because you are personally offended by
something that's a comedic set that this
person should be cancelled and deleted
out of this whole world and he called
everything that was gonna happen that's
yeah even funnier yeah cuz you're I
don't know it just makes people look
more ridiculous that they're mad at the
fact that someone made a joke about
something exactly and then they call
them out about it it's like the [ __ ] and
on the other end - this is my opinion if
if there are people on the other side
where I read a couple of tweets from
comics and they're like well you know
you shouldn't
you shouldn't be offended blah blah blah
it's just comedy I think that's pretty
stupid too because you can't tell
someone not to be mad
exactly so like anybody who watches this
and they and they are upset that
somebody doesn't like it I think that's
[ __ ] dumb as well because they are
completely in the right not to like it
that's what comedy is about yeah so it's
it's weird because there's double
censorship happening right is people
trying to censor comedy because it's too
harsh and they're people trying to
censor other people's emotions and
feelings and joining them how they
should feel about something and that's
not the case either I think that what
comedy goes out people are allowed to
interpret it the way that they [ __ ]
want yeah and like you said they clicked
on his face yeah they clicked like
that's the that's the weird thing to me
about how [ __ ] works now is like people
are watching the whole [ __ ] thing
yeah and then they're getting mad about
it or they don't even watch the whole
thing and they see a snippet being
passed around on Twitter and then from
that one little [ __ ] snippet that's
taken out of context they write a whole
entire damn [ __ ] opinion piece about
it and it's like did you watch the whole
thing yeah yeah and I mean I think
everyone has every right to be upset
that's fine but then petitioning to get
someone cancelled to get to ruin their
[ __ ] and not let them like speak and
events and things like that that's what
I'm not cool with it's dumb it's it's
it's [ __ ] comedy and they treat him
like he's the leader of the KKK like
that's like the [ __ ] you have a you have
a choice to not watch his stuff and not
support him but there's a huge fanbase
out there that does right hey you're not
gonna change that fact you really aren't
yeah you know what I mean
and I don't understand that's why
sometimes when I go to these comic clubs
I see comics who are very apper and by
the way I love going to come close
because I just like laughing yeah you
know I'm not one of those comics that
sits there and crosses his arms and like
- it's not funny no I literally go their
tongues you're not like competing with
them internally like the others luckily
ninety comics yeah I'm trying to laugh
with a [ __ ] ass off men and there's a
lot of great comics but there's a fat
bunch that creates content based on how
other people will perceive them yeah I'm
not really saying what they feel now
well yeah cuz they just want to be
famous or some other reason or they just
want to be liked right they don't know
how to have an opinion exactly like i ah
you can have an opinion that kind of
caters to what people feel but it
it feels very disingenuous when I could
tell when people can tell especially in
the crowd that you're saying these jokes
just so they can get the crowd on their
side yeah it's it's it's weird it's like
you're not saying anything yeah there's
there's no content based around the
stuff it's a circle jerk yeah it's it's
it's odd and like I feel like a comedy
club should be a safe space
there's comics who go out save space to
say whatever you want yeah yeah there's
comments who go out there right and if
you look at their set and they say some
crazy offensive [ __ ] and it doesn't work
out yeah they take that and on the next
set they tweak it or they're still
saying the same thing but they're doing
it in a way where it can be digestible
yeah so sometimes or digest it they see
it and they go that was a terrible set
this person's trash no that's the comedy
club these are major comics that are
going into work they're [ __ ] set
yeah I think right now though with
recording everything and then just like
putting it online and whatever like
people only have one chance to [ __ ] up
right but they don't understand stand-up
comedy culture in general
well there's comedy rooms and people go
to these different comedy clubs because
they're of that different culture like
there's black comedy clubs there's like
hipster comedy clubs or whatever and you
know what you're gonna get that night
like you're not gonna get a white
supremacist that walks in and does like
[ __ ] racist jokes all day yeah like
you know like this comedy club it's
gonna have this night right and you kind
of walk in and and and and you look for
that but then since everything is
[ __ ] recorded now it just goes online
and it goes to different crowds that
it's not supposed to go to yeah and one
of the critiques that I read on it was
Dave Chappelle's comedy is solely done
out just for shock value and if that's
what you thought when you saw that
comedy shock jock or any of that [ __ ]
cuz he was saying some funny [ __ ] yeah
he constructed jokes like you know like
the whole louis c.k thing right yeah the
people who have made that a similar
louis c.k joke just like Dave Chappelle
did but the way he executed it was so
[ __ ] funny yeah it was time and it
was it was hit making a commentary about
how weak guys are after they come yeah
you know what a guy looks like I thought
he comes [ __ ] like panic Banerjee's
dress
laughing at that [ __ ] because I saw the
walrus I saw that dude just coming yeah
it is harmless looking yeah and so
that's that's the comedy any people even
came at certain Asian people they're
like well Wyatt this is weird too when a
white person comes to me and says well
why weren't you offend him when Dave
Chappelle did the Chinese joke
Dawg that [ __ ] had me [ __ ] dying and
it's because he's not making fun of
Asian people no it's just ridiculous
yeah just showing he's showing you how
ridiculous it is to him and why that
topic that he was talking about was it
comes off to him is funny yeah right and
so it's you got to be a dense dumbass
not to understand that like I think it's
got a it's got to do something with like
IQ and understanding how people
communicate because when people don't
get comedy or they don't get satire they
don't get these other you know like
there's there's tricks that are being
played and then there's you got to
understand a perspective and whatever
right but if it goes over their heads
and they're just super literal about
things I really questioned their ability
to think like the motorman just dumb
this podcast is brought to you by
vistaprint
my friends now I'm a business owner and
as a business owner I have some business
cards that I always be handing out
because I need it necessaries in my
life's you know what I'm saying I own a
few food businesses and on top of that
this podcast as well and want to connect
to people on an instant without having
to worry about them jumbling through
their phone and making sure they have my
contact I just pass out my business card
number one it shows that I'm
professional and number two it has my
contact information everything ready to
go right there so they can access it
whatever they want sometimes people just
don't want to sit there and punch in
numbers in their phone and if anything
what I can do as a business owner when I
am at mixers or I need to show people or
give people my contact I have these
professional business cards and it shows
and I'm really about my business so if
you go on this website vistaprint.com
you can plug your information and logo
into hundreds of fresh designs tailored
to your type of company or upload your
own original layout
pick the paper stock style and quantity
that's right for you you can even
upgrade to a unique touch like rounded
corners order and receive your cards
with free economy shipping as well
now Vistaprint wants you to be able to
own the now in any situation which is
why our listeners will get free shipping
on all business cards and style and in
any quantity that you want so just go to
vistaprint.com and enter promo code
brain for free shipping on all business
cards any style any quantity limited
time offer so own the now at
vistaprint.com
promo code brain you support our show
when you support our sponsors there was
like I said I say to like we I did this
10 Foods episode and I mentioned on a
dumbs podcast was there was his like
Korean girl why did apologize to only
because not because of what I said I
didn't apologize for the joke that I
made I apologize because her feelings
were hurt and she was offended people
don't even know the difference man yeah
so you don't want to hear like they just
want to say hear you're sorry so then
you're you're wrong to that exactly so
this is how literal this human being is
so onsen foods is this joke where I go
you know Tim is famous right so when
somebody walks up in screen and they
come up and talk to him I'm like that
person's trash whatever it right and
clearly it people 99 percent people get
it the person is not trash
I'm the trash person exactly why it's
[ __ ] funny it's funny because it's
reversed exactly right and so this
person took everything [ __ ] little Oh
Mike well there was these two regular
just pretty-looking Asian girls yeah and
they were just walking outside look at
these floozies right they just they
don't look like floozies they just look
like regular people that's why it's
funny if they were floozies I wouldn't
have said it because it does it's - it's
the low-hanging fruit yeah it's like
calling a grandma hooker it's funny
because it's grandma obviously she's not
a [ __ ] hooker that's exactly what I
said it was it would have been funnier
if it was a grandma yeah you know and
the joke isn't that you're a floozy the
joke is is that I am salty because
nobody notices me exactly that is the
joke and this person went on this whole
tirade about and the thing I got really
[ __ ] matter and the reason I
responded to her so negatively was it
where was a tirade on Twitter or was on
it was on Instagram she goes this is
what she wrote and this is the audacity
of where she goes
women are you gonna let davis so talk
about us women that way like she made it
into a sexist thing and that's why i got
mad was that she tried to turn it into
something where it was like us women
against david so and i'm like you mean
me david so she thinks that you're
walking around saying ho ho ho ho [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] exactly and so i could and
and it wasn't even her that's probably
she's that's how literal she is so
[ __ ] literal wow and then her friends
she got her friends to tag or basically
take the post down yeah and there was
one guy that it was on there he goes you
know what women i don't want i don't i'm
not gonna let him represent us men I'm
like bro you it's not gonna get you
[ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up dude [ __ ]
white knight yeah he was like the white
[ __ ] night dude it's clearly one of
her [ __ ] friends and her sister was
going off and I was basically telling
her sister was it like a whole family of
dumb asses basically and so they don't
understand and most people are like bro
that joke isn't about you how do you not
[ __ ] understand this and so you know
they're like well you took the post down
so you obviously knew you [ __ ] up but
I didn't think the post knowing you guys
got to take him down I want to kept that
post till this [ __ ] day well you had
an Instagram post yeah we had to delete
it off the channel and everything cuz it
was a clip in the in the in the same
thing and she was like hitting up
instagram everybody dude and so I
apologized to her because I talked to my
mom about why is this situation wrong
she goes well your joke isn't wrong well
my mom said she oh there's nothing wrong
with a joke she goes but the problem is
is that she became a butt of a joke
without her really knowing and she
doesn't understand it then she's gonna
be mad every day wise woman so she was
like just apologize because you hurt her
feelings but don't apologize for the
joke yeah and I was like you're right I
should apologize for the feeling for for
her feeling that way Wow and um yeah so
I so I apologize to her I was like you
know I talked to my mom about it and I
understand that you're hurt I'm not I'm
not thinking about the joke but that's
some low IQ [ __ ] so what I'm what I'm
getting from this and I think this is a
part of council culture and all this
stuff is their interpretation is the
only objective thing that exists yeah
and no one else's interpretation is yeah
oh is is right yeah so if she interprets
it as you called her a [ __ ] ho a
floozy
a [ __ ] whatever and she she took it as a
literal
then and she thinks that your intent
then this is this is what's most like
lacking is people don't understand
intent right she thinks your intent was
you're trying to oppress her you were
trying to talk [ __ ] to her you were just
randomly calling her a [ __ ]
like why the is I don't even know why
you would do that but if she really
thought that then that's why she's
motivated to like take you down and all
that exactly and it wasn't even [ __ ]
[ __ ] it was like look at these floozies
it's floozy exactly such a childish word
you know it's like you it was a look at
these loose women you know it was such
like the most mundane way to say it at
all and that even then almost tiptoeing
a little bit right and so because I
would have been look at these [ __ ]
[ __ ] and you know just just exactly
just to prove my [ __ ] point - right
so her other friend that was there right
yeah she messaged and said hey I don't
like I get the jokes because I
understand but I didn't like it cool I
would have taken it down like that yeah
because of how honest it was she wasn't
trying to attack me no she was like hey
it kind of hurt my feelings
although oh [ __ ] and so it wasn't even
heard that got the content removed it
was her friend who said hey I understand
the joke but I didn't like it and took
it out like that you know why because
they came at me like a person yeah and
so I understood the situation the way
she was coming at it then and by the way
they're not even friends anymore because
she's such a [ __ ] really I found it out
after the fact that they're not even
friends anymore because she there was
this you know this is long story short
but basically you know she got an
apology the other one because she came
at it very nice yeah and she got mad at
her because she got an apology first so
she cut her out see that's just
problematic Pete exactly so that's the
individual yeah so people could say what
they want that goes to show the
character of that human being that's why
um when people are loud and crazy and
whatever they're like this is the small
minority this is what people don't
understand the people that lead this
like crazy cancel culture the people
that represent like like the weird parts
of feminism or like different movements
right yeah they're the most craziest
[ __ ] up in the head people with real
big [ __ ] problems yeah they're like
the worst right it's not the majority
like the majority of we
in the in the feminist movement like
they're not these crazy irrational like
people that are always looking at
[ __ ] men are the enemy same with like
every single group I see I feel like
most people are just kind of being
swayed by the craziest people yeah and I
know just not to sound like too
insensitive I can understand when the
other big part of the reason why I took
it down was because I think the her
individually she got affected because
there was like you know people in the
comments they were joking around so I
look at those loose women and they just
would read it and they didn't understand
that they understood the joke so they're
because a human being is so [ __ ]
literal reading into these comments like
oh not everybody thinks I must [ __ ]
slag because David so called me a
[ __ ] slide now the whole entire world
thinks I excite vote for free they're
making fun of me not you ya know but
because it's so once again too literal
it is it's just you can't explain that
to a person even after was explained she
still didn't understand and she goes I'm
glad that you're gonna change to be a
better person I'm like God you even
that's having that response after the
apology it means you don't understand uh
you don't understand what 99% of the
people understood so it's like why am I
talking to a brick wall your feelings
were hurt I should apologize for that
David it's not even me being a bigger
man that's my fault it's like I can't
convince a idiot yeah it's I hope
someone marries her and is patient and
can deal with that oh no and the [ __ ]
funny thing was is like to me she just
looked like a regular pretty Korean girl
yeah I've had a couple of my friends
like sent me her Instagram [ __ ] it's
like her like at a Vegas pull just
basically getting butt naked like not
saying that makes you a floozy or [ __ ]
or anything but it's mighty maybe you
uncovered an insecurity maybe she does
[ __ ] a lot of guys and she's insecure
and she doesn't want to own that maybe
maybe that's what it is because I wasn't
so if I was so shocked why she was so
offended yeah I mean I I know a lot of
like closet like sex lovers that are
hardcore
you know preachers kids or Christian
kids and and they hid the hate they hid
the [ __ ] out of that stuff you know baby
maybe you're right maybe I was something
that she was probably dealing with in
her old life like trying to be this fake
like demure like yeah and she doesn't
want to you know have that label because
it makes her feel guilty or what
like I'd own it like I mean I guess guys
are just a little bit different because
it doesn't do anything but I'm also a
scoundrels I don't give a [ __ ] about how
people say but yeah I guess I mean your
mom's right man if it hurts someone's
feelings and it's just causing like
negative energy in the air even if
you're not wrong about [ __ ] I think it's
just better to kind of like let it go
and move on and not have that kind of
attention around you yeah because I
can't explain it to her what sucks is
that you know it's hard as comics to not
avoid that unless you're doing some
remember that Joe Wong guy that did the
clean comedy oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
funny but yeah if you're unless you're
going super clean yeah and even add that
I'm sure I'm sure they're gonna upset
somebody yeah and I just I don't know if
you noticed like I just recently just
stopped caring cuz when I when I started
playing this game of Who am I offending
and Who am i hurting
what do you care what did you stop
caring about I think I just I got
worried about being cancelled because of
everything that was happening yeah it
started to affect me it started to
affect me a lot and they started to make
me not want to do stand-up comedy
anymore because um I felt like comedy
sucks now so why even do it when when
did you start feeling this I think when
all that canceling [ __ ] started
happening and like years ago like the
Amanat know like a couple of to three
years back I guess that's pretty well
back but it's one like the whole D
monetization thing happened and people
were saying what content was safe and
okay yeah and I got a little discouraged
to be a part of comedy anymore because I
stopped liking comics yeah I stopped
when I started going to these clubs and
people weren't making me laugh because
everything was the same [ __ ] because
nobody wanted to say what how they felt
or nobody was bold enough to take now I
would say nobody but I say like a good
handful starting to become this these
comics that didn't want to say or touch
topics that were taboo and make it funny
because they were afraid of black
backlash it started to deter me to want
to do comedy more because then it's like
what what group am i a part of now like
I wanted to be a part of this group
where you know we could take tragedy and
turn it into comedy and then when you
take that when you put censorship on it
and you take that away from us
it's like then what do we have left I
don't know and comedy too by the way if
most people don't know it's a big coping
mechanism a lot of comics man yeah it's
a huge coping mechanism meant like I say
this too why is it that you don't want
to hear jokes like for example like
remember on Dave Chappelle mentioned the
whole Kevin Hart thing right yeah he's
basically talking about a situation like
in my situation with the floozy thing he
goes he Kevin Hart is talking about
taking the dollhouse and pricky and hold
his kid's head how ridiculous do you
actually thought that this was something
he was going to actually do
that's as ridiculous as saying like I'm
a [ __ ] Wiley coyote your ass exactly
and it's like he doesn't even exist yeah
and and it's it's it's so far-fetched
right but once again the literal team
yeah takes it as oh this guy's gonna
abuse his hand tight - he's gonna abuse
his child if he ever finds out that the
child is gay no he's making fun of
himself for eating hat even having
thoughts about this this set standard of
what manlihood should be exactly he's
making fun of himself that's the [ __ ]
joke that's why people were laughing
they weren't laughing and cheering
because he's gay bashing yeah they're
not laughing at the fact that he's Chuck
in a dollhouse on a child although that
imagery is funny but I mean there's a
[ __ ] there's I mean then it would just
be plain abuse and it's not funny
exactly and it's so sad that people have
to explain their jokes now like we have
to extend when people put warnings
before jokes
then I hate ball and it possibly flow
yeah there's more in in after the joke
you have to kind of like clear the air
to make sure that anyone no one's really
there that never used to happen before
you just executed yeah it didn't [ __ ]
matter man and I mean this is kind of
how I feel about JK news too is that
we've really chilled out over the years
and we really hold back over the years
oh for sure man and and you know for me
like that's hard for me that's the
hardest thing it almost makes me feel
like my I to rip my [ __ ] skin off
like it's it's so difficult and that's
why I like the whole you know cuz I
started at patreon yeah and the reason
why I like that is because I cannot I
[ __ ] refuse to do that yeah same here
like on our patreon I feel
right now yeah whatever the [ __ ] we want
man yeah whatever we want whatever we
want and the cool thing about that is
too is that I and I and I say this all
the time I'm okay with people not liking
it yeah
have an opinion just don't go off and go
on this tirade about you know cancelling
somebody you're trash or whatever you
could stay why you dislike something
that's completely fine and that's
actually what Spurs great conversation
and great content yeah it's just what
you do after you feel that way is the
part that [ __ ] things up a little bit I
just I for me it's more about like
Dimona D monetization yeah because like
one of the biggest reasons why we censor
is not because you know we're worried
about what other people will think or if
they hurt us or whatever but it's
affecting the livelihood of my crew yeah
and once we don't get advertisers we
don't get paid because advertisers are
scared to like promote with us cuz
you're just too damn opinionated you
know and then it started to affect how
people are getting you know if they
could [ __ ] eat or not yeah I'm just
like man for having an unfavorable
opinion for cussing for doing things
that people don't agree with we're not
doing anything illegal or you know we're
following all the guidelines but then it
sucks cuz our videos get D monetize or
some channels get hurt completely only
because they have an opinion that
doesn't fit with the majority yeah and
to that point too when people say they
give examples of brands right yeah no
these are family-friendly brands for
example Huggies pampers or whatever you
know Johnson & Johnson whatever that
company is for for kids products right
do [ __ ] thugs not have children to
[ __ ] like the [ __ ] are you high
you don't understand everybody got kids
[ __ ] [ __ ] boys like everybody got
kids what are you saying we're saying
what is that [ __ ] mean yeah I would
do a pampers [ __ ] commercial of a do
getting out of prison all tatted up just
doing it's like a baby's diapers of [ __ ]
like [ __ ] we need diapers too
that would be a dope ass commercial that
would be it like the whole advertisement
thing did it makes sense and I think the
biggest point that was proved
that money rules everything was the
whole Logan Paul situation right not to
bring that up in bash and I'm not really
but this is a great example of Logan
Paul he did a video recording somebody
hanging from a tree and prior to people
making a big deal about it it was fully
[ __ ] monetized you know fully [ __ ]
monetize fully when we put up a video
now before the moment it touches the
internet space do you monetize yeah
amazing they're still making money I
think that we made 14 mil alast year
that's what I'm saying yeah it's like so
if people think that it's a moral ground
it's not money rules everything they're
not gonna [ __ ] touch their little
cash cow they're not insane with us
right so we have to adjust beasts based
off money yeah like but if people donate
to the patreon your arm saying yeah we
can be the same quality content that
everyone cared about so for sure I think
that's where the the world is kind of
going to like getting support directly
from the fan base and then you know
Adsense is gonna I feel like it's gonna
change though like the pendulum always
keeps swinging right so like there's
gonna be too much censorship and it's
gonna swing the other way again yeah
someone's gonna break that mold it's
gonna keep going back and forth back and
forth yeah for you um because you
started your whole Jill Molly and
Academy what's that about so uh Jamal
Ian Academy actually is because well for
one I mean you know me like I've been
burnt out and I haven't been posting on
my personal channel I put all my efforts
into JK and other things and when it
came to my own thing
vlogging wasn't as fun as it used to be
you and I actually like vlogging man
like I never did it for work like I like
going on trips vlogging capturing
moments and I actually would re watch
those vlogs when I got a feel good yeah
and then I would watch yours and in like
Bart's and then I would watch the
different perspectives right but then
the moment that I started having like
too much work on my plate like all my
vlogs became I'm so [ __ ] stressed out
because I'm working this or that and
it's like literally my chance to vent
and then you know relationships in
reality our ups and downs right so if
I'm going through a hard time with Jess
I'm not the type of person to be like
hey
sup guys our relationship oh absolutely
now we'd be [ __ ] no I'm the guy that
turn on the camera be like [ __ ] shits
it's crazy and so yeah if we're not
going to a good time like I don't feel
right vlogging in the house around her
because that also disrespects the
relationship and the integrity of it all
yeah so that kind of brought me into
this place where I was a I was I had a
weird relationship with my channel and I
lost the passion behind it and I would
post from time to time but it just
wasn't the same again and then I started
thinking about you know basically on
genius brain you know when we had Joey
over and in times I talked about finance
and I talked about other things a lot of
people keep asking me questions about
like oh how do I do this with my [ __ ]
bank or my credit card or like how do I
save money and there's like super basics
right and I started thinking about the
majority of the world and we're not
taught like normal [ __ ] like like normal
life schools that's that skills that
school should be teaching you like how
to [ __ ] balance your [ __ ] bank
account like like basic [ __ ] like if I'm
making this much money I shouldn't be
spending this much money but they don't
know how to budget right like people
don't even know what Apr interest rate
all that [ __ ] in a credit card is but
they sign up for it they [ __ ]
overspend and they go holy crap now I
owe this money and I get charged extra
money what's going on oh that's [ __ ]
great dude yes awesome
Jamal Ian Academy is literally a school
about [ __ ] that they should have taught
you in school or just life skills so on
their the way I'm creating these
programs it's really a voting system so
people that are part of the citizens of
Joe Mallya page I just like have like
kind of a forum there where they go hey
I want to learn basic finance or how to
make money or whatever and then
throughout this whole list
I'll just see whatever is the most
popular and I'll create that and in that
is giving me energy to create stuff back
on my vlogs again to where there's a
purpose behind like it's almost like now
I remember what it meant to say like
teaching good things in a bad way yeah
because I do enjoy
like whatever I learned to package it
through comedy and font and lifestyle
and like I think that's what I've been
doing throughout my whole entire YouTube
career is like whether I'm doing JK news
JK party JK films it's always a message
that I'm packaging through like
entertainment yeah and now I have that
like purpose again to where oh I want to
just like teach dope [ __ ] but then I'm
like meaningful [ __ ] that's gonna
upgrade the lives of my fans you know
yeah yep that I mean the reason why I
like that is because I think that
there's a lot of people out there who
are afraid to say I don't know these
bass exactly and so when we have
conversation yeah and it's embarrassing
when I say a lot of people I'm talk
about me in my early 20s cuz I didn't
know this type of stuff and people will
mention credit-card [ __ ] APR I'll this
other stuff and I would just nod my head
and act like I knew everything yeah then
you open up the fine print and you're
just like what the [ __ ] is this
yeah what the [ __ ] happened is I got my
credit card bill isn't going down I've
been paying this off every month and I
don't know though about these things
because of the interest right I don't
know that I didn't know that paying off
your credit card immediately is for sure
it's way better than you know holding on
like there's are so many things that you
just don't [ __ ] know that I wish I
was taught and it's stuff that my
parents didn't communicate to me as well
as sometimes maybe even my parents
didn't know and they're just kind of
winging it too and then they're
embarrassed but all this stuff is um
it's free yeah cuz I just wanna you know
it's like my way of giving back cuz my
fans have watched and helped me
basically live my dream right so it's
like what can I do to improve their
lives and so I'm just putting money into
all of this to just keep it going
and so it's it really like I've been
actually doing this for the past year
and a half yeah and I first came out
with the program called
how to find your passion because a lot
of people don't even know what their
passion is and I feel like there's
already a lot of stuff out there on how
to pursue your passion but a lot of
people don't even know what their
interests are or they're just like I
don't even know where to start right
yeah so I created that had a couple
thousand students I actually charged for
it but something that something just
didn't sit well for me cuz I was like I
feel like I'm being like those self-help
guys and that's not what I'm in here for
like I just want to entertain
but also like improve the lives of
people and even though I made money on
it I was like how do I do this in a way
where more people can see it so I just
decided to like redo everything and just
give out these things for free yeah yeah
that's amazing dude yeah there's just
yeah that whole I don't know thing is is
a really it's a hard pill to swallow for
a lot of adults because it makes you
seem very incompetent it's embarrassing
it's very much embarrassing man and it's
hard to be it's not easy to be somebody
who doesn't get embarrassed easily right
yeah that that's okay with having flaws
and and faults right
there's even in that situation where um
right apologize to that girl even though
she didn't
she's I mean listen if she's listening
to this I'm sorry I just think you're
really slow but what if she's like your
fan so she's listening she's not a fan
for sure especially the way that she
responded to me she was like it's like
the only reason I say that is because I
could response even or at the apology
was super disrespected in know she was
super disrespectful she goes now that
you're a better person like she's
speaking down to me like I'm trash
so she's Tim's fan she was she was but
remember after her friend got an apology
she said that her friend's trash and she
moved on from her like that's how the
word is toxic she is but either way it
was hard for me to do that apology thing
you know it's because and I had to own
up to the fact that I didn't understand
oh I did it wasn't very empathetic
towards that girl's feeling it was very
hard for me to apologize and say I was
wrong I was wrong for 50% and I got it I
kind of really just put that in because
I refuse to take the joke back but you
were wrong the joke wasn't wrong but her
feeling terrible was yeah I didn't
include her to the joke so I'm once
again I'm really sorry for that but [ __ ]
you yeah but it's it's just a difficult
thing that a lot of us have to do when
we're older um and I think when you
become older too it's hard for us to be
vulnerable dude why it is because you
don't want to feel stupid because you
feel like you should know already right
but I mean I got I got dm's and messages
from guys they're like yo man I'm 33 and
I [ __ ] I'm thinking I think god yeah
I went by this building called chase and
I said why these [ __ ] chasing
dog because like bros a big dude look
what you're talking about they just
didn't know and I feel like
intimidating cuz when you get your you
need a private which is awesome exactly
that's [ __ ] dope man yo sign up for
jamali an Academy man if you don't know
[ __ ] you about to see my name on
there with the alias yeah it's like
Jamal Ian academy.com baby say Robert
Wang yeah hey bro what is APR like house
be Jo yeah it all kind of came like all
that wants to because we recently
released the JK news where TIFF talked
about how I helped her out with her like
debt and everything yeah and then we
came up with a plan and a strategy to
get that all out so yeah I feel like I'm
pretty passionate about that like it's
really fun so in order for me to create
content there has to be a purpose behind
it right yeah I don't like just [ __ ]
around with the camera and although it's
fun from time to time like it gets to a
point where you're just doing it now to
meet a quota and there's no like heart
behind it I gotta have heart be here
what idea
I got you that's awesome dude I mean
that for us too I think a big part of
what we're doing now and the reason why
we've been able to really start pushing
out content again is because that
passion is back yeah it's hard for us
not to do things with passion because I
think it's very people can see it and
it's they could feel it it's very
tangible for our fan bases when we do
stuff that's not yeah it's not alright
we're not completely in it and it's hard
for me to put out stuff with I'm not
happy about it because I mean nothing I
put out too is ever perfect right
there's always something that I hate
about the stuff that I put out but as
long as my heart's in the right place
I'm okay with putting it out so I'm glad
that we're kind of getting back to that
spot hell yeah dude cuz we've been in a
rut for the past three years yeah it's
been kind of rough man but that's where
there's three years it's been it's like
almost three right almost three yeah
it's it's been rough yeah but hey I
think we're gonna come out of it and
turn into a phoenix come out of the
[ __ ] ashes and yeah [ __ ] tame that
sucker down I mean that's why the
podcast is still going strong we're like
almost this is like 70 something
episodes in and by the time this one
comes out [ __ ] and you know it's not
easy doing something that's consistent
unless you like it yeah I mean [ __ ] dude
like we [ __ ] miss you over at JK
music but I could talk to you for hours
yeah so this is
that really work this is my this is my
other Jacobs yeah I just did a twenty
percent of JK news here you know you got
the best cast maker well guys that's it
for this podcast man great great
suggestion for a topic I like topical
things because we could really dig deep
into a lot of this stuff yeah shoutouts
to the girl that try to cancel me you
know once again I'm really really
[ __ ] sorry that you felt that way but
at the same time ooh I hate your guts
but I [ __ ] apologize and that's
called a day me so apology so you guys
can catch us on Spotify iTunes podcast
basically stitcher any audio platform
out there make sure that you guys give
us a listen to and any of you not just
put that [ __ ] on repeat anyways cuz you
know we're giving out some some gems and
great conversation and the reason why we
have this podcast is to basically
accompany you throughout your mundane
lives because sometimes you just need
some people to talk [ __ ] and talk to you
all day that's right that's what me and
Joe are here for so we will see you guys
every Thursday and Sundays we upload and
catch you guys next time
toodaloo peace